let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony
michaels hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
well hello to all of you out there good
wednesday afternoon
it is three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
and you
are listening to let's talk
the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
and today
we have a lot of governors out there
republican governors in particular that
we are going to talk about
but there's a few things that i want to
get to before
we get to the gqp governors
uh first off
this friday i believe we're going to
release it this friday at the same time
that we do the podcast on wednesday so
that'll be three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern we're gonna have a
special guest podcast and i hope we can
do more of these
uh in the future where we still have the
live show like we have right now on
wednesdays and then we do a special
guest episode because it's so much
easier to record with a guest
beforehand
and then post it up on the interwebs but
here's what we're gonna do this
technology is fantastic i know nothing
about it by the way
this technology is fantastic to where i
can take a recorded session with a guest
a special guest episode and stream it
live
just like we would right now like i'm
live right now but this friday we have a
special guest episode and that special
guest is jimmy kennedy he is the
executive producer of the knollcaster
podcast now you guys know noel cass
casler uh he's on twitter he's a
comedian out of new york city
he worked with donald trump he does car
rants and he asked the podcast but he
worked with donald trump on the
apprentice so he has all these fantastic
stories
uh about donald trump and uh
frankly
they're hilarious
uh because you know
this facade that you see the donald
trump that you see is not really the
donald trump you know
not in front of the camera so noel gives
a good insight into what that looks like
so jimmy is his executive producer on
his podcast and he joined me the other
day for recording and we're gonna
release that podcast this friday
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern jimmy kinney executive producer
of the no castler podcast he's also the
host of his own podcast jbk on air and
you can find him jbk on there on twitter
and instagram so go over there follow
jimmy pay attention on friday we're
gonna have the very first
friday special guest podcast
thank you jimmy for joining us and
you know
maybe there'll be more of these special
guest friday podcast so stay tuned to
that
and the next thing i want to get to
speaking of special events the next
thing i want to get to
before we go
um talk about republican governors
because i also want to touch on
the infrastructure decade that we have
because uh democrats and republicans
passed an infrastructure bill and then
the democrats passed a bigger
infrastructure bill in the senate this
morning so i want to talk about that i
want to talk about the senate also dick
dick durbin slam dunk josh holly and
corey booker totally destroyed tommy
tuberville
i want to talk about those things too
and we'll get to those gqp governors who
are totally
uh botching this delta variant in their
states
not just with the mass mandates not just
with
with the uh kneading ventilators but
there's a lot of stuff going on down
there so we'll talk about that but the
first thing i want to get to
first
is what us liptards are gonna do when
mike lindell drops all the great
evidence that he has it's gonna change
all of our minds
i i'm sure you've seen that the the
mypelo nazi the ceo of my pillow mike
lindell is holding a three-day cyber
symposium
in south dakota
you know the home of cyber symposiums i
guess i don't [ __ ] know who knows
who knows
and it's in an effort to push these
these false claims that the presidential
election was stolen
by joe biden when we know we clearly
know when the evidence says that joe
biden won and kicked his ass by 8
million votes
not only that
but the actual truth of who was trying
to steal the election wasn't joe biden
and the democrats
it was donald trump and jeffrey clark
we know that now
and we're going to know more and more
and more about it
and that has to do with the senate too
so we'll get to that when we talk about
the senate possibly
but this cyber symposium was absolutely
fantastic i mean if you're looking for
plenty of comedic material this is the
place to go
i mean it it is
do these people even get that they're
dumping buckets of irony on top of
themselves
what the [ __ ] are they doing i mean the
clips of mike lindell just it looks like
he was taking not lunch breaks but
but freebasing cocaine breaks crack
breaks
[Music]
this guy has to still be on drugs right
either that her he fried what brains he
[ __ ] had
if he had any he french fried those
[ __ ] had two of
i said on twitter that
the marbles had lost their mike lindell
that's how far off this guy is
is that he hasn't lost his marbles the
marbles have lost him he's
out there boom like a firework
so
and you gotta go watch these clips
uh on the internet of of this absolute
[ __ ] show
and i posted a uh a clip from a prior
podcast on youtube uh
talking about mike lindell and it was
obvious that the mike lindell trolls
were all over youtube
and the reason why is because i go i i
post this video this clip about mike
lindell
giving his pantsless interview i think
you guys remember this he gave that
interview where he was pantsless and
then he was he was claiming
you know i don't know something about
august 13th or september 89th i don't
know
you can't tell with these people anymore
they're so far gone
so so i posted the video the clip of a
podcast and i believe it was from
episode 30 last week i i posted a clip
on youtube you could tell all the mike
glendale my pillow trolls the russian
trolls were out on youtube because they
were pounding me with comments you know
i'm a marxist and
mike lindell's a hero and he's an
american hero or what whatever the
[ __ ] delusional thing they want to
have
they were commenting
but
it's obvious
that
the strategy here is to just
dump as much
misinformation as they can
on as many people
who will believe it because a lot of
people are listening
but not a lot of people are believing
this stuff and the reason why if you
look at the pictures from the event this
was not a packed event folks people
weren't beating down the door to get in
this event and the reason why is because
it was exactly what everyone thought it
was going to be
a complete circus
in the first 45 minutes they couldn't
even get a presentation to play
they were blaming it they were blaming
on they or them whoever the [ __ ] that is
they or them were hacking into their
systems or some [ __ ] and and here's the
thing
they couldn't get the presentation to
play
and we're supposed to take these people
seriously about
at a cyber symposium
about hacking into machines and and
cyber stuff you know the ninjas or
something i don't know audits
i don't know
how the [ __ ] are you supposed to tell
anymore with the bamboo ballots and
the the chinese watermarks and ah you
can't tell with these people anymore
what the hell is gonna come out of the
garbage can that is their mouth
so
the best part though is there was a big
reveal
right mike glendale is supposed to
provide us the american people with
enough evidence that is going to make us
go to washington or or or force joe
biden and
and kamala harris to resign at the same
time which would give you president
pelosi number one the gq
gqp kryptonite nancy pelosi she would be
president
madame pelosi
madam president pelosi
so i don't know why you would want joe
biden and and kamala harris to resign
all at once right now but that seems to
be the plan
but
he's supposed to give a big reveal that
is to convince the entire country
the entire country
that
someone was trying to steal the election
and the evidence that they provided
was a county clerk
from colorado and of course this is all
seems really staged
but she comes out on stage
at an uncertain time
and she says that hey
i
know that the election was stolen and
the reason why i know the election was
stolen is because the secretary of my
state
is raiding my office as we sp as i flow
here as i flew here
as we speak they're raiding my office in
the election room the voting room or
whatever the [ __ ] she's talking about
now
this is a county clerk in colorado
in case anyone is wondering how most
states work now not all states work this
way but most states work this way you
have county officials that are in charge
of elections you know getting your voter
registration card getting poll places
making sure people are on the rolls that
are supposed to be on the voting rolls
rather they moved or they didn't move or
if you did move which which location are
you supposed to go that's the county
clerk the the county voting officials
their job to make sure all that's
organized now
the thing is
is the state actually sets the laws
the federal government and the state
government it's really the state
government sets the laws for voting in
your state rather it's early voting or
or what the ballot looks like what
machine you're going to use all that
kind of stuff all right we we know this
because the republican party right now
is trying to pass laws in all these red
states to prevent people from voting
because they don't want people to vote
because if people vote they'll vote
against them because their ideas [ __ ]
suck
now
so there's a county official that's in
charge of
voting
and then because the state is the one
that passes the laws
for voting there's a state official
well in most states in most states that
state official
is the secretary of state
normally
that would be the person who is in
charge of voting for that state in other
words they're the top dog when it comes
to voting
and they were elected that's how it
works in a democracy in a democratic
constitutional republic we vote for
people to represent us and the secretary
of the state of colorado
was voted in to represent the people of
the state to make sure that part of
their their job is to make sure that the
elections are free and fair
so
the secretary of state of colorado would
have the right
and
probably the cause to do audits
at county clerk
offices you know
because they're in charge of elections
and the secretary of state is in charge
of those people in charge of elections
how do we not know this
how do we not know this and the other
[ __ ]
clown show clown shoes
[ __ ] circus act that happened with
her on stage is she says the reason why
she knows the election was stolen in
november is because they did this raid
this morning
what
so you're telling me a raid a raid
raid
you [ __ ] break a raid a raid that
happened this morning
is the reason why the election was
stolen
10 months ago
11 months what
what the [ __ ] are you people yapping
about
what does a raid today have to do with
the election being stolen last year
are you are you people really that far
from tethered from reality that you
can't put that [ __ ] together that the
secretary of state is in charge of
elections in a state like colorado that
the county clerk
is in charge of elections in that county
and the secretary of state of that state
of colorado
would not only have the right but the
duty to make sure that maybe that county
has an audit and they get you know
they're doing the right thing
by the way i hear and i'm not sure this
i didn't look this up because i really
don't give a [ __ ]
at what county what district this
person's from
but apparently
this county official is in is in part of
the district that lauren bobert is
elected to in colorado which
i'm not saying
those two have anything to do with each
other but what i'm saying is is the
people who elected lauren bobert if they
have anything to do with electing a
county clerk yeah you could see that
right
you could see that kind of [ __ ]
these [ __ ] boneheads
so that's that's their big that's the
big reveal that happened yesterday is a
raid that happened the day before the
morning of the the first day of the
cyber symposium the raid it's not a
[ __ ] raid
they probably sent out a letter said hey
we're gonna do our normal yearly visit
to your office
but they'll eat it man
these [ __ ] spread necks they'll eat
this [ __ ] like twinkies
they'll eat this misinformation like
twinkies and the reason why is because
that's all they want to hear also they
want to hear a [ __ ] that they can spew
back
uh on facebook
at libtards
to tell them how donald trump won
because he didn't he [ __ ] lost
he's a [ __ ] not only did he lose he's
the biggest [ __ ] loser in modern
history
and and not all not
not only did donald trump lose by 8
million votes there was someone trying
to steal the election it was trump
and they were trying to steal it after
the fact because they couldn't get
enough people to vote for him
and really
the way our election
system is set up in this in this country
by the states having control secretary
of state's county clerks you know like
we just talked about it's really hard to
rig up an election it's really [ __ ]
difficult it would be really [ __ ]
difficult trust me george soros has
tried a hundred times republicans and he
pays us all all kinds of money to do it
we just can't figure it out otherwise
we'd have 60 senators and we'll get to
that here in a minute why we need 60
senators and the next time george soros
pays all of us libtards to rig up the
election we really need to do a better
job get the [ __ ] out of here
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
you're dumber than a bag of goddamn
hammers
with this [ __ ] the only person that
tried to steal the election was donald
trump after the fact
because he lost and he hates to lose
because he's a he's a [ __ ] whiny
little [ __ ]
and he didn't want to lose
well there's a lot of reasons why he
didn't want to lose
but he doesn't want to be known as a
loser that's why he's got to get every
time he's got to get in front of a
microphone he's got a you know someone's
got to stroke his ego or stroke is
whatever
if you could find it to stroke his ego
to make him feel like he actually won so
he can live in this delusional universe
you know like he lived in a delusional
universe when he was doing the
apprentice
that's what he should have done god damn
don't you think that that him being the
president united states was the worst
mistake this [ __ ] ever made and
he's made a lot of a lot of shitty
mistakes holy [ __ ]
i mean it's a big pile of [ __ ]
a big pile of steamy [ __ ]
but being president united states was
the biggest one
he could have been still on the
celebrity apprentice pretending to be
the best businessman ever in the world
pretending to be a great businessman so
successful
nope
couldn't do that had to have that tower
in moscow didn't you [ __ ]
had to make sure that that you got your
tower in russia so that you so that way
that way you could be the chaos agent
here the united states during the
election and really bang up our
democracy for putin so you could get
your tower how'd that work out for you
huh
how'd that work out you cheeto dust
mobster
so mike lindell
is on stage losing his [ __ ] mind the
whole time and just
at one point they want to go to lunch
everyone in the room's like hey we're
[ __ ] hungry mike we know you're on
crack and you don't need to eat a
bologna sandwich but we'd at least like
a peanut butter and bologna sandwich or
something
something jesus christ
a [ __ ] vegetable tray crackers and
meat i don't know jesus we need
something popcorn this is entertaining
as [ __ ]
he's like no we're not going to lunch
you don't get lunch we're playing a
video and he's losing his mind right
losing his [ __ ] mind he says he says
i'm i'm gonna be on this stage for 72
hours straight i'm not leaving the stage
because
you know
i don't know
i guess the longer you stay on stage and
spew the same old [ __ ]
the more true it gets i i can't figure
this [ __ ] out
but later on
later on
after he said he's gonna remain on stage
for 72 hours he's not eating lunch he
reads a tweet and i forget who the
[ __ ] tweet is from now but he reads a
tweet live on stage he's reading the
tweet off his phone which i don't even
know how this [ __ ] gets on
twitter it had been someone else's phone
i mean it had to have been someone
else's phone because he can't get on
twitter he's [ __ ] banned
him and the mypelo account is [ __ ]
banned you're [ __ ] banned [ __ ]
you can't get on twitter what are you
doing
say the [ __ ] off twitter
we canceled you remember cancel culture
us liberals canceled you
so get the [ __ ] out of here sit down and
shut the [ __ ] up
so he's on twitter and he's reading a
tweet from a reporter i don't know if
they were in the room or not but he's
reading a tweet from the reporter
quoting him what he said quoting him
what he said and he says i don't
remember saying that do you remember
saying that and it's it's hilarious
because half the crowd's like yeah yeah
i remember oh no no yeah we remember you
saying it but i don't think you want us
to remember you saying it
he said it he said it
these p he is on [ __ ] drugs
he's drinking that steve bannon's
definitely been drinking because steve
bannon gets out on stage with him
they're sitting at the goddamn table and
steve bannon is trying to start a civil
war here i mean he's really he's really
reaching he's really reaching
for that civil war because they really
want this august 13th thing to happen
they want on august 13th for donald
trump to uh arise from the dead from
mar-a-lago and ascend into the heavens
of washington dc and become
uh king or president or dictator or i i
don't know adolf twittler i don't know
what the [ __ ] they want really it's very
unclear what they want
because they can't they can't have any
kind of coherent idea about what august
13th even means
and we're bailing bailing in on it here
and even mike lindell at one point he
says they're not going to believe the
evidence even when we show it to you
they're not going to believe it well i
thought the evidence was so [ __ ]
compelling that we're all going to
demand that the supreme court annoy
anoint donald trump king
and forget the constitution forget the
united states forget the democracy and
the republic that the experiment that
we've been doing for the last two
[ __ ] 100 years forget all that forget
all that
we're just gonna let the supreme court
anoint a dictator
that's that's literally what they've
been saying and then he says on the same
breath he says they're not going to
believe it no one's going to believe
this nothing's going to change and even
he even goes as far as to say they they
could convict and arrest everyone in the
room and the world in the country in the
country they're going to convict
everyone in the apparently we're all
going to prison for voter fraud all of
us republicans democrats liberals
they're going to arrest us all who they
are i haven't figured that out yet but
they are coming for you
holy moly
jesus
talk about a woodstock
god damn
jeez
cyber symposium
three days of this [ __ ]
there's gonna be fantastic fantastic
clips fantastic videos so all you video
editors out there because i know i'm
talking to liberals because
there's no way there's decent ass uh
conservative republican gqp cue it on
uh video editors because if you see some
of their videos they [ __ ] suck
they're horrible
so video video editors get your [ __ ]
get your computers ready because there's
going to be plenty of it for you to edit
out of this cyber symposium
that's going to lead us up to january
excuse me august 13th
the day of days
that's going to
i don't know we'll see
we'll see
now
let's get to some real [ __ ] as opposed
to that [ __ ] la la neverland fantasy
[ __ ]
democrats and republicans pass
the small infrastructure bill
in the united states senate
uh bringing back what was thought to be
a lost error
era of policy
you know bipartisanship as they call it
that's what some people call it
um some people some people call it
legislating because that's really what
it is that's what we're experiencing
here folks
the thing is
we happened
to nominate a candidate in the
democratic party
who is a legislator that's what he is
he's a legislator joe biden did it
for many many many many years
and he is doing it currently now
i'm on the fence about some of these
things like the voting rights act
joe biden wants to preserve
the
filibuster
and somewhat of its current form i guess
because he is the old guard legislator
but it is obvious with this bill
that more than donald trump could ever
dream of and really that barack obama
wanted to have
joe biden has the ability to legislate
here
we got the coronavirus relief package
done
they got the small infrastructure bill
passed with 19 republican senators
including mitch mcconnell
now i'm going to talk about that here in
a second
but they also passed they also passed a
three and a half trillion dollar
infrastructure
uh bill that is going to go to
reconciliation
um so that they can get to the house
because nancy pelosi has already staked
her uh
uh her foot in the sand and said hey if
you don't get the three and a half
billion we will not bring this uh
smaller uh three and a half trillion
dollar bill we will not bring the
smaller bill to the floor
so if you want your small bill you gotta
have the big bill which uh this morning
democrats passed with 50 votes uh to
to do the three and a half trillion
dollar bill in reconciliation so that is
good news on that front
uh and the best part was when joe biden
came out to talk about the the
infrastructure plan yesterday the two
bills because it is two bills the
infrastructure plan is now two bills and
there's a reason why it's two bills but
it is two bills it's political
but the reason why he came out and
talked about the two bills is because he
was very confident when they got 19
votes on the small bill from republicans
mitch mcconnell
even voted for it
now there's a lot of significant uh
policy here there's a lot of significant
investment here and i'm gonna let i'm
gonna let
all you lefty liberals out there
uh argue over what joe biden said and
what is gonna happen and who's gonna get
what money and where the money's gonna
go
and what it's gonna pay for and all that
[ __ ]
what i'm gonna talk about today about
this bill and about what happened is the
significance in the in the politics in
this country because that that is one of
the most interesting parts about this
because we it's been a long time since
we had a real infrastructure bill in
this country i mean even joe biden said
it after years and years
after years and years of infrastructure
week we're finally gonna get an
infrastructure decade
which was a fantastic dig on the former
guy the cheeto dust mobster and it
pissed him off which is even better it's
even better because he was furious and
that's where the politics plays into
this folks donald trump with this bill
passing not only the first bill but the
second bill passing as he is becoming
more and more irrelevant every single
time joe biden gets something done every
single
time
that's why we have a lot of these
republicans governors pushing back
on helping uh save their citizens
from this delta variant
because
if they help
make sure their citizenry is safe from
the delta variant by god it's a win for
joe biden and they just can't have any
of that
even if it means children in the
hospital or people dead their
constituents dead that's a sacrifice
they're just gonna have to make
to make sure that that donald trump is
still relevant
because that's that's the fear here
is that he's not relevant
because he's be he's getting more and
more irrelevant as time goes on
and as joe biden gets these victories
it's more and more irrelevancy
and especially once these victories come
to pass
like the coronavirus package when
everyone got the money dumped in their
account
boy that was a that was a that was an
easy receipt wasn't it
of
of trump's irrelevancy
because you remember at the end of last
year and here's why at the end of last
year and they passed the 600 stimulus
right it was 600 bucks and he came out
said i'm not shining it it should be 2
000
and i'm going to get my 2 000 i don't
give a [ __ ] what you say get your asses
in gear and do two thousand dollars i'm
gonna go play golf see ya
and they were supposed to come up with a
way to make it
two thousand dollars
well
as time went on he realized that he was
going to be blamed for not getting the
600
so he signed the 600
package and everyone got 600 bucks
and joe biden said well i'm going to get
you the rest of the 2000 i'm not going
to get you another 2 thousand i'm just
gonna get you the rest of it the
fourteen hundred bucks
i'm gonna get that for you and i'm gonna
work on it
not only that we're gonna make sure that
we do everything we can in this country
to get rid of this virus
as long as you do your part america
the government will do our part it's
basically what the bill was
so he passes it the the 1400 hours that
trump couldn't get because he's
worthless and he was golfing not working
joe biden got
bam in the account you remember it when
it hit boom
party time
party time now it's not near enough
not near enough for the [ __ ] that we
put up with
for the for the year before that
but joe biden followed through on donald
trump's promise
of getting the two thousand dollars he
did that
and then now it seems that
joe biden is going to follow through on
the promise of getting this country a
really good investment of infrastructure
not just in the way of roads and bridges
but also in the way of broadband
rule internet
real internet
rule high speed internet you know those
rural areas those real blue blue
binaries those those areas where they
vote for biden
he's going to get him high-speed
internet
he's going to get him high-speed
internet
that way maybe they can look up you know
actual facts
on how to how to how to mitigate this
virus maybe they can do that once they
get that high-speed internet
i doubt it maybe they'll spread around
more queuing on
conspiracy theories
but the other politics that plays into
this because you have 19 republicans
voting for it
that also
that also is a clear signal that the
republican party is seeing donald trump
is more and more irrelevant every single
[ __ ] day that ticks by
he was yelling and screaming course he
doesn't have a twitter he's got you know
i don't know i guess it's like the pony
express out of mar-a-lago
when he he writes something down and
i put it on horseback and
they ride it up to you know the western
union office and
they get on the
on the morris code machine
send out a telegram i guess i don't know
i don't know how he gets out his uh
his tweets now but apparently he was he
was a little pissed off and he was
threatening you better not vote for this
you better not give joe biden a win and
make me irrelevant you son of a [ __ ]
i don't care if i promised america
infrastructure or not you better not
give it to him
you gotta wait until i
am the the supreme court or
or i speaker or i win pr or something on
august 13th whatever whatever the pillow
nazi says that's gonna happen on august
13th you better not do anything until
then because i'm gonna take credit for
the
for the infrastructure because we had
infrastructure week all the time when i
was president all the time we had fire
trucks that came and i sat in the fire
trucks and the dump trucks and and and
the excavators we did all that we did
the whole reality tv show thing we did
that whole thing we made sure that the
country thought that we were actually
going to pass infrastructure
we we did everything we could to to fake
it
and now now that i'm gone now that i
lost my eight million votes even though
i tried to cheat to win
now you're gonna you're gonna make it
you're gonna you're gonna vote for this
thing
of course they're gonna vote for it
here's why 19 republicans voted for the
smaller bill
because they have to run a lot of them
have to run for re-election next year
there's going to be a lot of house races
all of them there's going to be a lot of
senate races
and republicans are vulnerable
especially
if democrats are the ones who pass
infrastructure
and republicans had nothing to do with
it because they saw what happened
they saw how popular the coronavirus
bill was when 1400 hours got dumped into
people's accounts imagine what's going
to happen when 800 000 jobs are created
over the next several years
imagine what's going to happen when
people start seeing their high highways
and bridges and and rural broadband
being brought to their communities
imagine when the healthcare
infrastructure improves can you imagine
holy [ __ ]
someone might [ __ ] notice
including their constituents because
what did happen with the coronavirus
bill is they didn't vote for a single
[ __ ] shred of it none of them
not all one of those [ __ ] voted
for it and then what they did
is they went back to their states they
went back to their districts and they
tried to take credit for it
and joe biden came out and said no no no
no no no no no no
your constituents get it but you
don't get credit you some [ __ ]
so that's what they're terrified of
they're terrified that the democrats if
they didn't vote for infrastructure
we're gonna pound them next year
for not doing a god damn thing
you gotta have something to run on
because the only thing you're gonna have
to run on right now is possibly the
former president's gonna be either
federally indicted or in a federal
prison for committing
sedition or treason for trying to steal
an election or go to federal prison over
his inaugural committee for taking saudi
money and laundering it through an
inaugural committee i don't know this is
just alleged stuff i'm hearing i'm
hearing from reports out there that
there's people being indicted
that there's people being investigated
that there's people like jeffrey rosen
talking to people and criminal referrals
might happen at a cent certain senate
judiciary committees
so yeah yeah the republicans 19 of them
at least
want to have something to [ __ ] run on
want to have something to put in their
[ __ ] pocket next year other than
having to tie their [ __ ]
their party to trumpism which is gonna
go down like a sinking boat
like the trump you remember the trump
the boat parades the trump whatever the
hell they call them
and and they had so many [ __ ] flags
it tipped over these boats and they were
thinking that's what's gonna happen
that's what's gonna happen the only
reason why trumpism is even hanging on
right now is because of this this virus
running around like it is
that's the only reason why
i mean we have all these governors all
these republican governors
completely
completely ignoring
what is reality
and playing to the fox news fan club
that's what's happening
you know this is wrestlemania
[ __ ] we got to please the fans
stone cold death desantis has to smash
the beer on his face
irregardless of how many fans
out there would die
that's what the fans want they want to
watch ron desantis stone cold ron
desantis
to smash the beer over his face
[Music]
and he did this
within the last 24 hours
he's been running around trying to
prevent local governments
rather be cities counties school boards
especially who are especially concerned
about young children being unvaccinated
in their schools and unmasked are trying
to place mass mandates to make sure that
their staff
their faculty their students and their
communities are safe from the spread of
this delta variant
that is filling up the hospitals in
florida
and this [ __ ] [ __ ] is trying to not
only not only uh uh
instituting orders to make sure they
can't mandate but he's really doubling
down on making sure
that these communities are not safe are
at least as safe as they want to be
i talked about this last week how
republicans used to lecture us on local
governments
how to keep the federal government out
of our local government we don't need no
big government in our small government
our small government can handle our
sales well now that small government
wants to handle themselves they're not
for it and the reason why the reason why
is because it's not part of wrestlemania
you're not following the plot
the plot is is that trump is right
even though he's wrong that's the plot
you gotta follow that plot
and you gotta make the fans happy you
gotta crush the beer on your face
ah
she's gotta do
and guzzle that son of a [ __ ] you know
regardless of reality
who cares if it's true because the truth
is
the state of florida asked for 300
ventilators from the federal government
and the federal government said yeah
we'll give you 300 ventilators if it
helps you save citizens
and a reporter asked ron to say desantis
this and desantis says that's not true
i did not ask for help from joe biden
don't believe it trump please don't
believe that i asked for help from joe
biden please don't please don't believe
it i didn't i didn't ask for help
[ __ ]
it's all show it's all to get the
highlights on the fox news
the oan the newsmax
you know
to make sure that that that cheeto dust
mobster approves
you wouldn't want him backing out of his
best imitator have you noticed that have
you noticed that ron desantis
have you noticed that he does a really
shitty impersonation of trump
he's got the overfitted stupid suit the
the long ass tie that hangs down between
his [ __ ] knees
he does the hand signals and the
chopping and he tries to do the cadence
he doesn't have the voice down
he really needs to go to a voice coach
for the for the trump voice he he
totally botches that
now he did fix his hair up a little
different to make it look [ __ ] stupid
you know you gotta have if you're gonna
look like if you're gonna be the the
impersonation trump your hair's gonna
look really [ __ ] stupid for this to
be believable so he really kind of
[ __ ] up his hair a bit he hasn't dyed
it yet but he did he has appeared a
little more orange than in the past
when he steps out in front of a camera
he's a little more orange seems like
he's really he hasn't figured out
exactly what brand
what brand of of spray-on tan that trump
has yet he hasn't figured that out but
he's getting there he's working on it
this [ __ ] guy
and then we have then we have the the
governor the governor of texas greg
abbott
so concerned about the coronavirus
he's doing the same thing that desantis
is
preventing local governments
from
from keeping their communities safe and
healthy
and he's he's botching that the
hospitals are so full down there that
they're asking for help from other
states and other health care systems
because they need help
they need bodies they need people to
treat these people
they need hospitals they need to send
these patients somewhere
they're full
they're full
and all the while all the while
this [ __ ] bonehead decides he's gonna
arrest democrats for protecting people's
but right to vote
that's what he's going to do that's
that's the ultimate ah that's that's
the fans the wrestlemania fans love that
oh yeah the trump pay-per-view boy
they'll love that they'll love them some
wrestling democrats that's a good idea
let's do that let's arrest us some
democrats woo
forget about forget about the reason why
you're arresting the democrats is
because they're protecting people's
right to vote because the texas supreme
court allows history to record
that democrats are protecting the right
to vote and republicans are trying to
take it away why would you want this
imagery think about this for a second
we're about to go into a huge huge
huge election here
we're about to enter that cycle
and the imagery you want
before an election where you're trying
to steal it by passing laws to suppress
votes in the states that you think
you're going to lose
your imagery that you want to have
is you who are trying to steal elections
arresting elected officials of the
opposite party
trying to protect the rights of people
to vote
that's the imagery that you want
that's the great that's the grand
thinking
i mean imagery is everything in this
country like
people really the only way we remember
things
is with imagery
rather it be
you know
visual imagery is in a picture or video
or
or sound and audio
i mean that's that's that's kind of
human beings
you know ask not
what your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country get
vaccinated and wear a mask
there's all kinds of them
there's all kinds of those audio clips
good ones
and bad ones there's a lot of good
imagery and a lot of bad imagery in this
country
and that's what they want right before
going into election
is to show that the people trying to
take away your vote are arresting people
that are trying to protect it just as
you go to vote to make sure that you
keep your right to vote
it seems kind of [ __ ] it seems kind
of [ __ ] off
but let me tell you let me tell you
the the executive producer of
trumpomania that's maybe what i should
start calling trump a mania down at
mar-a-lago
the executive producer down there and
that's what he says the fans will love
the fans will love it all the fans will
eat it up the fans the fans
will eat it up that you arrested
democrats forget about the people that
are going to go pile votes on top of
your dumb ass
because we see we see this dumb [ __ ]
this hypocrisy this
mania maniacal morons running around
even in the senate
just last night we watched tommy
tuberville
he gets on the floor of the senate
and and late into the night he decides
that it's gonna be
this huge maga victory and he's really
gonna had those democrats
and what he's gonna do is introduce an
amendment
that make sure
that states can't defund the police
that'll get them oh boy that'll get them
those democrats because they're they're
for defunding the police they'll do that
oh man it's going to be awesome we're
going to have the fox news moment for
the trump mania fans the trump mania
fans are gonna love this woohoo yeah
just like they love ron desantis not
taking ventilators from joe biden and
the biden administration so that way
floridians die ah yeah that thing oh
yeah pew pew pew pew pew we gonna own
them libtards
so tommy tuberville gets up and he
introduces an amendment to make sure
that states and local governments cannot
defund the police
and it gets voted 99-0 every
[ __ ] democrat voted for it and
cory booker gets up
and just dunks on this [ __ ] says
he says something and i don't have the
quote in front of him but he says
something like well why we're adding why
we're adding d uh uh making sure that
people fund the police which is is an
american as you get maybe we should add
in apple pie or something like that he
really dunked on him pretty good
and then josh hawley after watching this
this [ __ ] [ __ ] josh holly from my
state of missouri well he's not from my
stadiums or he lives in virginia he
represents missouri he's never he
doesn't live here he doesn't have a
house here he just represents us because
missouri's bunch of dumb bucks that vote
for people who don't live here and don't
want to be here and don't want to come
here you know they want to live in ritzy
places like you know virginia live near
washington dc you know just pretend to
be here use their sister's address or
something like that
josh hawley thinks it's a good idea
after watching corey booker slam dunk
that [ __ ]
tommy tuberville
he thinks it's a good idea to go on the
floor and basically
introduce the
the cops legislation it's it's kind of
the same legislation and he says we want
to hire a hundred thousand more police
officers now i mean i'm all for hiring
more police officers especially if
you're gonna arrest insurrectionists
like josh holly if that's what we're
gonna do
is go out and make sure we clean up this
this
these [ __ ] criminals these crooked
ass politician criminals that we have
out there i'm all for a hundred thousand
new cops and i'm sure josh holly is too
but josh hawley doesn't see this coming
he thinks i'm going to own the libtards
i'm going to get on trump a mania the
trumpet mania fans are going to love
this woohoo i'll be the world champion
maybe i'll be the tag team champion with
tommy tuberville
the tag team champions
well
dick durbin gets up and hands josh and
takes josh holly's ass off of him and
then hands it to him
hands it to him jen sockie's said
[ __ ] that's going to be a new
verb he jin sakes
that [ __ ]
totally slam dunks that son of a [ __ ]
and basically let's josh holly know in
front of the entire [ __ ] world that
the amendment that he just introduced is
the bill that joe biden passed when he
was a senator back in the 1990s whether
you like it or not he basically josh
hawley just handed up joe biden another
victory which makes josh hawley and
donald trump even more irrelevant
on [ __ ] live c-span tv
totally dunks on that [ __ ] nba
jam
he's on fire type [ __ ]
jin saki's that [ __ ]
right there in front of everybody fan
[ __ ] tastic
and dick durbin at the end says i'm so
glad that you support the legislation
that joe biden
passed in the 1990s oh it was [ __ ] it
was beautiful
the only thing that would have made it
better the only thing that would have
made it better is to have a camera right
on josh holly's face zoomed in to really
get to really get that [ __ ] eaten look
on his face when he realized what the
[ __ ] he just done
that's what this is
it's all a show
all of it the mike lindell cyrus
symposium
ron desantis trying to refuse to let
local governments govern the way that
they want to govern themselves to keep
their communities safe
and acting like he didn't and his state
didn't request 300 ventilators because
that would be giving joe biden a victory
joe biden would look like the hero if
people knew that i requested ventilators
from him
oh my god can you imagine if someone
thought that ron desantis really cared
about his citizens and wanted
ventilators to make sure that he could
keep him alive because he had convinced
them not to get a vaccine and not to
wear a mask and now they're hospitalized
and they're dying because they need a
ventilator
can you imagine we can't have that as a
plot on trump a mania
that won't play well with the fans
you gotta crush the beer on your face
so here we are
here we are laying it out cold
seeing the trumpomania show
and that's why
that's why
they are using this virus they are using
the vaccine they're using mass mandates
they're going to use
vaccine passports they're going to use
vaccine requirements for employers
they're going to use all this stuff to
try to continue trumpism
and i know it doesn't make any sense
because you're like wait a second why in
the [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ] would people who are
dying from this virus
be convinced to send them money
after they're trying to do the things to
tell them to do the things that are
killing them why would they do that i
know it doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense i i know that but
it's because it's trump a mania tv it's
trumpomania it's trumpism now if we
didn't have this virus running around
the country and everyone would have got
vaccinated back in april and may
when everyone could and should have
gotten vaccinated so that we didn't have
this variant
running around the country getting
all
people sick it doesn't matter if you're
young old good health bad health you're
getting sick most of them are being hot
a lot of them being hospitalized and
some of them are dying
healthy young people it's happening
now
the reason why we have this is because
that's the last they gotta hang on to
trumpism somehow
i mean how else are you gonna have the
trump show when the democrats and 19
republicans are passing infrastructure
and doing the things that that donald
trump promised he would do and was too
much of a buffoon
to even get up in the morning to put on
his shoes to do those things you know he
had the golf and he had to tweet
you know he had to do those things
and he had to you know steal an election
and launder money he didn't have time he
didn't have time to [ __ ] around with
infrastructure
he just needed to you know have fire
trucks and dump trucks come so he could
get in semi trucks and get in and act
like he was driving you know just to
fake it fake it till you make it you
know well they're making it now now that
that motherfucker's not in charge
and that's what they're scared of here
is that donald trump is gonna be deemed
irrelevant because they really hitched
their [ __ ] wagon to him
they've hitched their wagon to him
they're all in they don't nothing about
deficits anymore they say nothing about
taxes
i mean jesus christ they don't even
mention the name ronald reagan anymore
have you noticed that
they don't even say ronald reagan
anymore it's like a bad word like well
he's kind of he's kind of a liberal
isn't he any one of them libtards that
ronald reagan he was kind of a lip dart
i mean compared to compared to adolf
twittler we got
the cheeto dust mobster he's kind of a
lip tart compared to our guy our guys
the badass
trumpet mania
2021
august 13th pay-per-view
bring it on you dumb [ __ ]
bring it on
i can't wait for august 13th to get here
and figure out what day they're gonna do
next and how it's gonna work you know
who's gonna have to resign
what kind of [ __ ] that that isn't
stated in any kind of constitution
anywhere in this country is gonna happen
to make donald trump the president
united states
i can't wait
and then when we get to indictment day
can you imagine when we get to
indictment day how interesting
trumpomania tv is gonna get
here's what i can say folks
here's the solution
make sure make sure you can vote next
year
wherever you live wherever you are make
sure you can vote
go get [ __ ] vaccinated right now
we're a [ __ ] mask if you're out there
and about
and amongst other [ __ ] spread deck
human beings
put your goddamn mask on let's get over
this virus because the good news is on
that these daily shot these daily shot
numbers are skyrocketing because these
people are watching people in their
community die that are unvaccinated
the
saddest part about all the death is it's
going to convince people to go get
vaccinated which
whatever reason we need but that should
not be the [ __ ] reason
we shouldn't have to kill another
hundred thousand people for everyone
else to get vaccinated and do the right
thing
do do adulting and [ __ ] you know that
thing you're supposed to do adulting
go get vaccinated wear a [ __ ] mask
especially if you're in these goddamn
spread neck infected areas
around these
morons
mask up and go vote next year go vote
and vote for the party vote for the
party that's going to get you stuff like
infrastructure that's going to get you
stuff like the john lewis voting rights
act
it's gonna get you for the people act
those type of things because there's
only one party that is for those things
only one
only one party that is for voting rights
and you're gonna see it you're gonna see
it because
the speaker of the house in texas is
already he's already started to issue
warrants to arrest those democrats that
are protecting voters that are
protecting voters in texas he's already
issued the voter warrant so we're going
to have we're going to have the video
evidence of it that they want the fox
news moment the oan
mania moment where they're arresting
democrats
or they're arresting democrats that's
what they want
it's oh it's going to be fantastic when
we watch a party who's trying to take
away people's rights to vote arrest
people who are trying to fight for
people's right to vote
here's another sound bite from you
maybe maybe you'll remember this one
and boy boy this sound bite
this sound bite
did not age well
and you'll know what i'm talking about
when i say it
it was a governor his last name was
wallace
he said
segregation then segregation now
segregation forever
and his aim was to make sure
to that people did not have rights
in particular
black people
in the south did not have rights
well
our imagery is about to come rolling
back around
when there's a certain party that is
fighting for the rights of people to
vote in texas
and the people who are trying to take
them away are going to arrest them
that's where we're at
while
while the only party in washington
trying to protect your right to vote
there's only one party only one of them
because if there was more than one of
them that was willing to protect your
right to vote your constitutional
[ __ ] right to vote
if there was more than one that
[ __ ] would already be passed
it's sitting right at the feet of the
senate
all they have to do
is get 60 votes or kill that [ __ ]
filibuster which is what they [ __ ]
should do
they should tell them to take that
filibuster and stuff it in their [ __ ]
asses joe manchin christian cinema
stuff it in their [ __ ] asses
so
vaccinated
go [ __ ] vote
go
[ __ ] bury these fascist [ __ ]
like tommy tuberville josh holly all of
them
every single trump candidate out there
bury these [ __ ] in a mountain
a mountain
of votes that's what we got to do
and
keep laughing at mike lindell because
it's [ __ ] hilarious
join me next week
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern live here on twitter
youtuber twitch and don't forget our
special guest episode on friday this
week i'll be posting out there on the
social media
and until next time
[ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them